[ __ ] together it's over the barbecues
the [ __ ]
how many cheeseburgers did you have
looks like you have a good fourth of
july i had a really good really good
weekend what'd you do lisa you know what
though and okay i have a story to tell
you and i'm not trying to make it see
i'm not bragging
so i was coming home from fourth of july
it was a long [ __ ] day and it was hot
because i went down and south we went to
a park and
the thing we [ __ ] up is apparently
down there you have to get to like 9 a.m
we got to the park at like 11 30. we
were done and
there was we got a spot in the shade but
we didn't get a spot with a with a
table so we they brought they brought a
bed spread from home not even not even a
blanket like a beach blanket they
brought a bread spit so we had a place
to sit but when you sit on the ground
for four hours it takes it out of you so
we're coming up to 405
and i was talking and i noticed a guy
pulled over and i don't i normally don't
notice but there was an old man with a
walker on the side of the 405 at like
four o'clock on the fourth of july and
paul and i were headed to the gym
and i don't know
anything about cars i don't know one
thing other than how to turn it on but i
was like there's an old man with a
[ __ ] walker on the side of the 405
and people are just whizzing by him
and i was like [ __ ]
so i said i said we have to we have to
turn around so we turned we got on we
got on the 457 went and turned around
and i got to him i had i was just gonna
go call triple a
sorry because i don't know i don't know
[ __ ]
and it's actually something i'm kind of
embarrassed about because i don't i
don't have to change oil i know how to
do [ __ ] so i pull up and this other car
pulls up and i look at her it's a
younger lady she's like are you here for
him she's like no
and i'm like what okay so i get to him
he has a blown out tire and then she
comes up there's two people with with
blown out tires and this old man just
has the tools
and i'm like [ __ ] i like he's he's
trying to do it he's like this old
southern guy i'm like i'll help you but
i have no idea
so i start i start helping him with it
and then this luckily thank god this
like 30 year old woman pulled over too
so she knew how to do it really whoa
um
so i learned how to change a tire and it
took [ __ ] an hour because it was his
front one so we took the back one off
and we put the spare on the back because
he didn't want to put the donut on the
front
and then we put the donut and then we
put his back one on the front and then
that woman who pulled over the first one
she had the
[ __ ] up one too so he had to change
her
her tire with his tools and took about
an hour
but i felt great like i was sunburned
afterwards i was like i was thinking of
you saying i was gonna get sun
but i had
i had no idea like i knew like the
theory behind changing a tire like just
the spinning the nuts or whatever but i
had never done it
and i did i did three of them that day
it was like i felt like i felt great
about it and i just felt so bad like
who isn't going to stop for an old he
literally had a walker with the tennis
balls on the side of the five and i'm
like no one's stopping for him you're a
regular johnny volunteer i guess you're
a bad mother i mean you you know how to
do it you could stop i mean i know how
to do it but i stop i don't [ __ ] know
it depends how i'm feeling got it but
yeah i just it's america yeah
and you know
you really want to believe that people
really care exactly but they [ __ ]
don't and the ones that walk around with
the badge on their chest that they care
and they're good samaritans those are
the biggest scumbags in the [ __ ]
world yeah you know
i'm happy that you pulled over and
helped the [ __ ] old guy you know the
mentality behind that that someday your
dad's gonna be stuck that's what i
thought of and somebody's gonna help him
you know that that's the mentality
behind those things like that but
you're living somewhere that people give
a [ __ ] about their careers
people don't look in the eye why would
why would they [ __ ] pull over to help
an old man why you're in the land of
fakeness
you're in the land of every [ __ ]
cause but the cause in front of them
yeah you know they're for every cause
save the dolphin save the shark save the
shark tooth
save [ __ ] everything
but the the the [ __ ] the cause that's
in front of him
as the one nobody ever sees and i'm
guilty of that also you know what i'm
saying i mean we're all guilty of that
but
who knows for you [ __ ] look at you
playing johnny [ __ ] triple a i feel
like i felt like i fell back no change
in [ __ ] i know
because when they jack the [ __ ] car
up they don't know how to jack it up and
it breaks and the people [ __ ] get
killed by jacks yeah oh [ __ ] i luckily
he told me he's like there's a little
lip
but do you know how to i i've changed
i've never known
i'm no [ __ ] car genius i could change
all if i had to
you know i don't know if i'll even find
a nut underneath to put the bucket and
you loosen it yeah and you know i could
change the oil filter if i had i could
change the air filter if i had to
i don't know about that [ __ ] no more
those days are a long [ __ ] gun you
understand yeah uncle joey's road
[ __ ] days i used to have this car and
i had every tool imaginable and to fix
that car yeah like i had a [ __ ] up
radiator but if you put one of those
things in the radiator it fixed it for
six months okay you know like you puerto
rican the [ __ ] car up you duct tape
it you know but that's pretty
interesting that you pulled over and
then yesterday you went to the movies
yeah yes i had paula for the weekend
and we you and i talked and we were like
well you could go to this bar
and at the end of the day like because
i'm we're trying to eat healthy you
can't get anything healthy and i never
buy pay-per-views but i was like well
i'm gonna spend 60 at a bar i'll just
we'll go out to dinner and we'll i'll
get up we'll do it here so we did that
and yesterday
we went with her mom and her cousin to
see that horror movie
it was nice it's not it's uh i've been
listening to what you're saying about
about
feel like family is important on the
weekends
and i've never been close with a
a girlfriend's family before and like
the mom the mom and i are getting pretty
cool the mom was making fun of me for
being scared of the movie and
it's uh
because the mom
it's a joke because i like her mom keeps
saying like when you leave me i'm going
to die but recently she said oh now that
you have lead i can i can die happy and
it's just how dramatic
like our like mothers get like when we
get a little bit older but i don't know
it's been cool you know you're uh
you're involved in the relationship and
you
you're part of their family it's so
weird when you get involved with
somebody's family like
uh i'm good friends with terry's family
i i like them i enjoy them you know
i can't be around them all the [ __ ]
time yeah you know i don't think i'll go
to the movies with those crazy
[ __ ] you know but
um i enjoy them i don't understand how
people are married and they don't like
the other person's families or you know
that that just causes [ __ ] you know
drama drama from the beginning and you
know at the end man
you want to be on those weekends around
with the people you love you know you
feel more at home with your family
whenever i stay at home sometimes lately
i don't know how to handle life
because there's a lot of sit-down time
with mercy there's a lot of well i'm
going to watch it for an hour when i
and i draw with her and i'm on the floor
and i'm watching videos with her and i'm
thinking to myself
i should be writing my book i should be
writing jokes by thinking myself no
i'm 51 years old i got a second shot at
this i should be spending time with it
this is what i feed
this family time yeah it's how i feed my
joke writing and your book's gonna get
done and yeah everything else will get
done if you don't if you don't live your
life you got nothing to write about
right you have nothing to write about if
you don't live your [ __ ] life let me
ask you something do you know exactly
what's going on with the opium anthony
thing do you know exactly for the degree
of things from what i read
he's saying he got punched in like times
square area taking a picture
and then he he he since deleted the
tweet so unless a little unless a
reporter saved him we can't i can't see
them
from what i read from some of them he
was saying she was like an animal which
is fine if i got punched in the face i'd
be pissed off too
to me it seems like he got in trouble
when he started saying something like
she's black and i'm white it's hard
being a white man and just going off a
little bit about that i didn't fully
read it but it seems like
he went off on on race and xm got got
scared but after how many decades of
them being on the radio i'm surprised
they still got scared
you know it's amazing what's going on
now and it's amazing i'm amazed by the
two
the two two things from this that
you have to be very careful with your
choice of words now
what happened to adam richmond too
the food chain yeah
on instagram he said something this one
he's even more stupid he said he was
working out and he used a hashtag it's
inspiration like to inspire people to
get them apparently
people are using that online to be pro
uh anorexia and this blogger got pissed
off at him
and then he he just responded like
anyone would and then travel channel
they didn't cancel the show i think i
think they just pushed it back a little
bit but
it's really amazing how sensitive we are
as a [ __ ] society yeah
and how uh you know we're run by
corporations and
they have a thin line of a thin margin
and [ __ ] uh
you know when they don't like something
you're [ __ ] house you know yeah but
the other thing about
this whole thing it taught me is where
the [ __ ] people's heads are and how much
we've become suckers
like we're becoming a [ __ ] society of
suckers all weekend long i kept getting
these [ __ ] stupid tweets about you
know show your support show your support
let me tell you something i love anthony
and i think anthony's a funny [ __ ]
guy
i think it's a great show and they do a
good job maybe in new york for a long
time but there's nothing like it
you [ __ ] guys are impressed if
somebody writes something like that
that's what you're impre you know like
oh yeah i'm supporting anthony you want
to [ __ ] support somebody go in front
of sirius
go in front of sirius the people that
work with anthony should say you know
what we're not going [ __ ] back to you
put them on you know nothing happens to
your [ __ ]
toilet it comes down to doe
and that's when people back the [ __ ] up
what happened to operation operation
what's that what happened to the
operation where we were gonna stop
corporations and people gonna live
outside what happened
what happened what happened
what happened you wouldn't put away your
[ __ ] phones so the commitment was off
you know you people want to want to work
on 30 commitment because somebody tweets
i'm supporting him i love the [ __ ]
guy but do i have to write everything
down to show my support and solid
[ __ ] dirty what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you people let me tell you
something a couple [ __ ] years ago a
man by the name of joe rogan who's got a
lot of [ __ ] faults but he's a
great guy and he's very [ __ ] generous
with his time used to go down to that
comedy store every [ __ ] week on a
friday and saturday and do spots for
free not only that he bought him a
[ __ ] sound system he bought him a
[ __ ] sound system okay ten thousand
twelve thousand thirteen thousand
dollars when was the last time any of
you bought a sound system for anybody
and one day he got thrown out of there
because somebody allegedly was a joke
thief and he put a video i don't [ __ ]
know and who gives a [ __ ] the moral
story is that friday everybody was
supposed to go down there and march for
him
and i'll tell you what what happened to
the [ __ ] march you know what the
people who were supposed to leave gersh
two of them left louis ck and david tell
everybody else [ __ ] stayed well
because the agent had this where was the
solidarity then you see solidarity ends
when it comes down to paper when it
comes down to you losing paper out of
your [ __ ] pocket that's when you shut
the [ __ ] up because
where's your solidarity where's your
[ __ ] commitment see me i'm the
different type of guy i don't give a
[ __ ] about money i was looking for a job
when i found this one and one way or
another i'll go pick i'll make a [ __ ]
dollar i don't need you [ __ ] or
this [ __ ] to make a [ __ ] dollar so if
i stand for somebody i go in for a
hundred percent till this day i won't
step foot in the [ __ ] comedy store
joe rogan's not my brother or my best
[ __ ] friend in the world he loves me
and i love him but it's it's the the
action is louder than me on twitter i'm
never good at the store yeah i don't go
to [ __ ] kill tony's and i love tony
hinchcliffe and i love red band they're
my brothers but you don't see me down
there in the morning like that's the
commitment you want to [ __ ] you want
to answer they get this job back cancel
your subscription don't tell me well
what am i going to do about [ __ ] uh
ozzie's boneyard what am i gonna do
about [ __ ] jim norton i have serious
too what the [ __ ] do you want us to do
so stop with the you know with the oh
well if you type something that shows
how much committed don't believe the
hype we're a society of [ __ ] suckers
your parents are raising [ __ ] suckers
to make us [ __ ] gullible we really
are we believe anything i'm good well
i'm support well look at him he's so
cool gotta [ __ ] together you gotta
hear what these people say behind closed
[ __ ] doors so just don't worry about
[ __ ] so much about saying something
on twitter that the whole thing it's the
[ __ ] actions that count if you're
going to commit to it 150
shut your [ __ ] mouth when you go down
to sirius and go you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] put a bomb in my nut sack and
i'm gonna pull this [ __ ] string if
anthony don't get his job back if you're
not gonna do that shut the [ __ ] up all
right with your little words you people
are the same people that got impressed
with channel son and where is he today
where is he today remember how mad you
guys got little jones is a [ __ ] he
won't fight him on three week notice
remember remember how they all went
where the [ __ ] is he now he's not around
no more but jones still is around shut
the [ __ ] up unless you're gonna you
people get impressed by the littlest
[ __ ] things oh my god well he wrote
on twitter oh well the [ __ ] out of here
get it together
get it [ __ ] together you [ __ ]
suckers stop being a sucker on your
[ __ ] life plus this is probably the
best thing that's ever happened to him
he gets to have his podcast now and
you know people are just so [ __ ] uh
was so into the words so well he said
that you know oh my god
he's such a good guy let me see him go
down there
and put up the [ __ ] guinness because
at the end of the line this is it this
is it adidas how much you putting up
what either oh nothing i can't quit my
job i have benefits shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] then shut the [ __ ] up what
happened to operation we're gonna take
down the corporations where's the stinky
basses in the tent they found out they i
need to use a an iphone to take pictures
of the stars you know oh my god if i see
uranus get the [ __ ] out of here you
[ __ ] jack bobs you're all the same
you're simple cut it out who gives a
[ __ ] at the end of the [ __ ] day
anthony will get a job and all you
[ __ ] that were we love anthony
what the [ __ ]
what'd you do i want to be around will
you bring it up a little bit cocksuck
it's friday july 7th get it together
stop being a [ __ ] sucker on your life
and believe in everything you [ __ ]
read on toilet
[ __ ] jackoffs
oh [ __ ] watch that muffler today's the
day it's your lucky day
get a lottery ticket do something [ __ ]
second
do you see your eye hall speech after
half day one that's pretty great who
you're right holla the guy broke his toe
like his speech when joe rogan came up
to him but how if you're not calling
your dreams you're just uh existing it's
pretty cool looking for the music
[ __ ] watching [ __ ] put it together
what
who
stands to be true
that misery loves company that's it
these [ __ ] want to see you down
who gives a [ __ ]
how was your fourth my fourth was
[ __ ] great man i went to a block
party
in studio city with the baby and they
had like this water thing they had a
band
they had uh
free food you know
hamburgers and hot dogs and cake pie
eating contests i seen dave grohl down
there hanging out
uh it was very interesting i had a great
fourth of july it was really nice to
stay home for
two and a half weeks i did the ice house
but it's time to get the [ __ ] out of
dodges yeah some jokes and going back on
the [ __ ] road
uh it breaks up my week a little more
you know i had a good week last week i
had a great time
very interesting for it i spent it with
them you know what what'd you think of
the fights the fights were great the
fights uh
ronda rousey is just unbelievable um
i didn't watch b.j penn i wasn't home i
recorded three rounds and my heart was
[ __ ] broken really
is he he lost yeah
it's all over if anybody needed
testosterone last night it was bj penn
oh it's not so bad you know but it's
crazy how
i was watching the weigh-ins the other
day you know
and
the [ __ ] funny thing is when you
watch the wayne's everybody on that
stage is on [ __ ] drugs really even
ariana celeste is doing something her
face is changing you know
dana's head's this big joe rogan's
head's this big fritida's head's this
big all you see is a [ __ ] bunch of
[ __ ] huge heads from the [ __ ]
testosterone the only guy that's not on
test is the black guy bud and [ __ ] uh
maybe he's even on testosterone the guy
that runs out bruce buffett and jumps up
and down yeah everybody's on [ __ ] even
the microphone was [ __ ] on
testosterone
you know everybody's up for the scales
on testosterone even the guy from nevada
is on [ __ ] testosterone it's it's
amazing it's amazing so they have like
you know it's a rampant [ __ ] epidemic
now that every guy you see and it's that
[ __ ] and it's not listen the thing i
i don't even know if you go online and
look at the percentages of prescriptions
they've given out
in testosterone in 2013 2012
it is
unfucking believable
it is unbelievable because it's to save
all
medication for older guys now it's the
one now they're they hooked on it they
know the verbiage they know the whole
[ __ ] deal with it and you know what
it [ __ ] me up because i'm a fat dude
like that fat dude shouldn't do it okay
a little nerdy [ __ ] like that
half a [ __ ] in the commercial you know
how you long test that yeah that
[ __ ]
he was he needed at birth do you see
jose consegues doing a commercial now
for for an
over-the-counter testosterone thing and
i'm like that guy did so many steroids
and they're having him do it
you know that [ __ ] guy dog did so
many [ __ ] things that poor guy
doesn't even know who the [ __ ] he is no
more
when you see him out you could tell he's
as confused as [ __ ] really i was [ __ ]
with him one time
at a ufc thing
i was tormenting him one time
i had never met him before i had never
ever ever met jose canseco before
and he happened to sit next to me with
his daughter and his wife at the ufc
and i started talking to him in spanish
and saying you don't remember me because
i had friends that used to go play
basketball
at his house about 15 years ago okay so
i would go to miami to do comedy and the
guys always say if you want to go to
consecos and play basketball i'm not
gonna [ __ ] say goes to play
basketball
so uh i saw him at this ufc and i
started busting his balls like hey how
you doing you remember me kind of
suddenly
yeah you look familiar you don't
remember me from miami 95 playing
basketball and i started dropping names
you know nick and
johnny been bananas and he's like yeah
yeah how you doing man a long time and i
started talking to him in cuba just
[ __ ] with him and that poor guy had
no [ __ ] idea i was just [ __ ] with
him where you're like you know i
remember that time we went to the
[ __ ] thing
and i started doing like cocaine things
like remember that time we're [ __ ] up
with your brother he's like yeah
oh my god that was such a long time what
are you talking about you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that sister the poor guy and then uh
frank mia came over who's also cuban
okay
frank may look at looked at the aisle
and he's like what's going on i remember
saying the remark about conseco and then
people started goofing on them
like people started throwing [ __ ] at
them
and they moved
they moved them from the area i think i
was a me ari and duncan
it was a big ufc like one of those big
summer ones yeah
and he came in and we just started
torturing him it's like [ __ ] stephen
cigar why he don't go to those ufc's
people start yelling at him calling uh
who shot bobby lupo
and all this [ __ ] master you know all
this [ __ ] he just
you know but these guys walk into it
i'm not gonna go in public if i'm one of
those [ __ ] momo's i'm gonna watch
that [ __ ] at my [ __ ] house i don't
want people throwing popcorn at me
i didn't know consequence that poor guy
what he's doing now wasn't he in tax
trouble too
probably he had tax problems so i mean
he's always doing those celebrity
fighting things when he had the reality
showing he couldn't get into his house
they they they put a fence around really
good house or something like that you
know i never saw that one no yeah they
did a reality show about them for like
six episodes oh that's funny that's a
that's a sad [ __ ] story man that guy
i went to see him i paid money
to see consecutive when i got married my
first time in 89 my honeymoon was in san
francisco okay to go see uh the oakland
a's against the [ __ ] yankees
i love baseball you know so i went
against the game
and it's amazing listen
i knew they were doing something
it doesn't take a [ __ ] when you see
somebody that big right away you know i
grew up in a time where steroids were
[ __ ] big in new jersey and everybody
was [ __ ] doing them for whatever
reasons
i just didn't like needles growing the
[ __ ] up you know what i'm saying yeah
thank god i popped a couple of those
anavars that they gave me one time but i
didn't i didn't i i just even with the
testosterone when i was doing it last
year
i felt weird
i felt weird like i was always doing
something i shouldn't have been doing
do you know what i'm saying like you
physically felt weird you didn't like
mentally mentally okay like i'm the type
of guy snorted coke for [ __ ] 90 000
[ __ ] years
but if i go to a doctor and he actually
pulled my pants down and put a needle in
my ass
i felt kind of weird like i was doing
something wrong you know
and i felt that way when i was young and
everybody was doing steroids and i would
get like a prescription of anavar and i
would take like three of them and lift
weights and then go i don't want to be
[ __ ] yolked up people gonna know i'm
doing them right you know why do
something that people are gonna i don't
know i just didn't see the well say what
you want about weed but let's just say
for a sake of argument there was
something you could take that would make
you funnier
when you do it
i mean it's like
i can see why if it was like if i wasn't
allowed to take it yeah do comedy
you know man listen
i was
a complete
piece of [ __ ]
when i was introduced to comedy
like i i
i shouldn't say it that way i was i was
introduced to comedy at a young age
but in my mind morally at the time when
i got into comedy i would do anything
i would put a gun to your head
i would break into your [ __ ] window
and granted i was robbing drug dealers
and [ __ ] like that i wasn't robbing old
people on the 405
when they got a flat i'm not that
[ __ ] much of a low life
so when i got into comedy i looked at it
as my last chance okay i really did when
i got into comedy that when i thought
about getting on stage and i took that
course and people like you're kind of
funny you should stick with this and
also the life presented itself i got the
biggest opportunity in life i lost i got
a divorce
i had to start all over again i had no
money
so i had nothing to lose when you have
nothing to lose you have nothing to lose
but one thing i told myself if i get
into comedy i'm not involving my life
into comedy
okay you know what i'm saying like you
know that after that um there's a an
actor that plays a lot of like bad guys
he was in uh usual suspects
he was also in uh a pulp fiction at the
end he's a guy they're gonna [ __ ] bring
rhames
oh yeah blue wide actor like that's a
guy that does drugs and he always gets
arrested and sometimes don't book him in
a movie and he won't make it to the
movie because he's doing time okay you
know i was supposed to do a movie with
him and the last minute they're like no
he's doing 90 days for probation
violation jesus you can't get out of the
half house and he's a great guy i met
him at the comedy store a couple 10 15
years ago i'm not judging him on that
i'm just saying that
uh i didn't want to be that guy i didn't
want to be
the guy that does time and then does
calmly six months of the year and i
didn't want to be that guy so when i
decided to get into comedy i decided i
made myself a personal [ __ ] promise
that i wasn't gonna involve my life into
comedy like whatever i had done before
comedy i wasn't gonna do it in comedy
okay so if i go to a comedy club and i
saw a purse with a thousand dollars in
it i wasn't allowed to touch it no
matter how hungry i was okay because i
didn't want
my character to ruin my destiny that was
the first time i practiced that without
even knowing it
i never had known what that was i didn't
learn that that saying until maybe five
years ago but that's the first time i
didn't let my character ruin my destiny
i said i'm not gonna [ __ ] let my
comedy get in the middle of this and
then i [ __ ] up a little bit in
97 on the road i got arrested for
shoplifting a tent
in boise idaho are you gonna return it
right yeah i was gonna do the return and
i got arrested and that's the first time
i
i uh disrespected comedy the the the
first time before that i disrespected
comedy just to get off the [ __ ] radar
before somebody asked was i got into
comedy jul uh june 18th
of 1981 was the first time i touched the
stage okay but uh
may uh memorial what is it saint patty's
day okay of 92
was the first and last time i did blow
before i got on stage and it was the
last time
i did it before i got on stage you
didn't like it no just so people know i
don't even mess with i would not do blow
before i got on stage okay if i had to
get on stage at 10 o'clock i would not
do a line of coke trust me it would be
hard but that was the discipline for me
at the time even though i was a junkie
okay i think in the [ __ ] 23 years
that i've done comedy i did a line three
times before i went on stage like just
because like in miami after i do two
shows yeah on those three shows
saturdays i'd do a bump and i would just
go on stage the third show and it was
just
people were impressed that i was that
high on stage
like i would get [ __ ] up i would drink
a bunch of uh drinks and people would
send me shots and that's what the
midnight show was about the midnight
show wasn't about the art it was about
[ __ ] going up there and being [ __ ]
up
is somebody calling me no
it's so weird how i never disrespected
my art
i never really tried to disrespect my
art okay you understand me so i thought
between you and i
if something could make me funny if you
listen to any of my conversations you
know uh
i was talking to
rizzo the other night to ha ha about a
week ago and we're talking about
when you first see the holes in your
game
you don't really see a lot of holes in
your game in comedy till you move to los
angeles
you know when you're on the road and
you're in seattle you're running with
your peers
so you're doing comedy and you're not
really seeing your holes you don't see
your holes and you don't feel your holes
till you get squashed in between nick
apollo and doug stanhope right or nick
apollo and jim gaffigan or any of those
great comedians who are very good at
what they do as a craft very set up
punchline
when you're in an unorthodox comic and
you're going in between them you see the
holes in your game
so it makes you work harder
you know i'm from the matt brown
institute of being funny i'm from the
chris weidman institute of being funny
it's about hard work i don't want to
hang out at the improv and hang out with
people and market myself and what do
they call it networking networking you
have a network you network on stage
right that's the best network there is
you don't network with a drink in your
hand and a joint in the other that's
where you end up [ __ ] dead and you
get this from me who was a [ __ ]
junkie i don't believe in that [ __ ] you
don't put a joint to your lips you don't
drink a beer
you got off stage there ain't no party
till you get off stage when people
called me on a weekend and said hi we're
getting married make their think good
for you
good for you i got a comedy show yeah
what do you mean you're not going to
come in san diego it's going to be fun
everybody's going to be there i'll be
there after i do a show
so the first thing i'm doing on may 13th
is i'm booking a show if nothing else
happens i'll come to your stupid [ __ ]
wedding
do you understand me that was my
philosophy yeah everybody wants to
[ __ ] uh go to heaven but nobody wants
to die that's how you do things you want
to become a better [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] things you want to become a better
student you study yeah when it came down
to comedy i did not [ __ ] around i sit
down one hour every day and go over my
notes
every day at some part of the day i go
with my notes i've been doing this for
27 years i don't need to do this yeah
but i need to stay current i love when a
person comes up to me after a show and
says joey i saw you six months ago you
did 20 minutes of new [ __ ] material
that means more than me than [ __ ]
anything it's not grade 8 10 o'clock the
[ __ ] you put on a cd but it's getting
there but at least something happened in
my life yeah you know
yeah and it's crazy like you said
earlier is you don't see holes in your
game until you move to la that's i felt
that way when i was going from high
school to college to do uh video stuff
in high school i won all the awards and
i i was the big guy for video and then i
went to college and the same thing
happened from college to here like
everyone's everyone's always the best in
their small town but then when you go
where everyone's doing you're like [ __ ]
they're better than i am you need to
keep [ __ ] improving
keep improving you know what all right
so last two weeks so i didn't write
comedy all week but i wrote the book
i wrote in the book you know i'm trying
to get a story ready for ari's show
september 9th but we're taping at the
cheetah i'm writing that you know people
think i go up there and wing it
sometimes i love for you to think that
and i thank you and i appreciate the
[ __ ] yeah i'm thinking in my mind but
at the same time i go in there prepare
let's get this
morning my friend
good morning joe how are you doing buddy
how are you my friend what's happening
and not much man it's another beautiful
day the sun rose i woke up so hey it's a
great day so far you scratch your balls
you sniff your fingers and you said
[ __ ] the lord lives [ __ ]
somebody's sucking my dick today without
a condom i'm showing up with a bag of
popcorn and a big dick and i got nothing
but time you're following me
every day every day is a show man this
is the show brent i'm so happy you
called today because uh
first off you're a [ __ ] gentleman uh
you're a young a young man and you're a
[ __ ] gentleman
you work over here at this little
vitamin store what's the name of it
oh it's nutrishop nutrishop they have
one in hollywood and they have one in
the valley
and even though we're uh was we're
sponsored by on it i get a lot of
protein powder from them i get sick of
using the same protein powder so i like
to switch it up so i wanted to see brett
one day
and he blew my mind with his [ __ ]
knowledge
brett was the first guy that told me i
had to eat something when i woke up in
the morning brett was the first guy that
told me about muscle you know you have
to put muscle on to burn more fat
and it's so funny brett that to you when
you were telling me
you know you thought you were just
talking to uh
you know a consumer that was educated i
knew nothing about this and when i left
you every time i leave you i think about
the people
that by not going and talking to a guy
like you are really missing the [ __ ]
boat
because absolutely uh you really know
you know a lot of people
don't get into shape and don't try to
get healthy because they're scared they
don't know where to start leave am i
lying to you i don't know what a [ __ ]
stuff you it's like a drug it's like one
night you getting on your hands and
knees and going god i'm sick and tired
of doing coke i'm sick and kind of
getting [ __ ] in the ass this has to
[ __ ] stop you know how do i stop
doing coke and getting [ __ ] in the ass
what do i do when you go to an aaa
meeting you put [ __ ] cotton balls
no no but you know i'm just trying to
[ __ ] around with you you know bret
people are scared
you know
how does a person in today's society
that's 60 pounds overweight and never
gotten to a gym when he walks into you
what do you tell them
all you have to start with the basics
man i mean you always have to start
somewhere in life with anything you know
but when it comes to uh you know your
health your fitness
it's a whole consistency thing it's not
something where you can gain your
success in one night
um you know you always start with the
basics you have to start with nutrition
of course that's where it starts with i
always think it's eighty percent
nutrition and 20 working out you know
say if you work out five days a week for
one hour a day you know you still have
23 hours left of the day to making sure
you're putting the right stuff in your
body so the true result factor really
comes outside the gym
and that's all based on nutrition man so
i'll always write out like a whole meal
sheet
um and it's a huge factor because you
know you have height factor you have
weight factors
uh you have activity factors you know
some people work uh like myself i'll
work a desk job all day i'm just pretty
much
stationary i'm not really you know
running around i'm not really burning a
lot of calories
so
maybe for someone who's uh not as active
i'm not going to be having them i'm
going to have a whole different type of
meal sheet that would be writing out for
him but now if someone is saying like a
ups driver who's hustling around all day
totally maximizing their calorie burning
depending if they're trying to lose
weight or put on muscle there's a lot of
different factors of of a person's
regimen and that's what i you know
that's why i always ask the questions
and and i try to break it down i try to
make it seem overwhelming for them
because there's a lot you know
um to know about nutrition and also
about supplements
but the beauty about the supplements is
uh
you know today in this era man we're so
busy with you know family with work with
hustling it's a full-time job to stay on
top of your nutrition
so um you know a supplement can make it
very convenient very easy you can
pre-load shaker cups with protein shakes
and uses meal substitutes
you can use multivitamins if you're not
getting all your full servings of fruits
and vegetables
um and so forth but you know
but at least at the nutri shop that's
you know that's what i love is people
coming in
by anybody walking into that door
they're already making that decision
like all right i'm gonna change my life
you know so they've already made that
decision so they've already taken that
first step you know and the rest of it
from that point it's just the
consistency and to stay motivated that's
what i always try to do too just
motivate people
whether it be uplifting their spirits um
i you know i always keep in touch with
my customers you know via email or
i always give them my personal number so
if they're out and about they have
questions they can always contact me try
to make it as easy as possible because a
lot of people do lose the uh
that motivation that that drive to make
them
feel you know good because it could be
discouraging you know when you don't see
those results right away so
so you always got to stay motivated and
stay connected with the people and
things that make you feel motivated too
you know
let me ask you this i have a big
question for you here
why is it so important to remember that
day i was in there and you're and the
owner of the store was there
and we were having a conversation the
thing he stressed
was eating something immediately when
you woke up
right well hey that's why they call it
breakfast because you break the fasting
of sleeping
you know when you wake up you got to get
your muscles first off out of that
ketosis state
you know that catabolic state because
you know say if you slept from you know
six to eight hours which most of us only
sleep really only like five to six hours
um you know you're pretty much fasting
you know so when we wake up uh right
when you put your feet on the floor your
metabolism it's revving up so right away
your body's looking for energy to burn
um you know if if you're not getting
food into your body you know you're not
nourishing the muscle so therefore now
your metabolism is attacking that muscle
and storing more fat so you got to get
those muscles on lockdown so right when
you wake up you need a good source of
protein
and even some light carbs too because
our bodies burn carbohydrates for energy
expenditure throughout the day
but most importantly you need the
protein to help protect the muscle
think of it as like i'm trying to think
of an analogy here uh think of it if i
put like a piece of filet mignon and a
piece of fat in front of you so which
which one are you going to go for man
the filet mignon
that's it baby
it's the same way it is with our bodies
you know we have we have muscle we have
fat in our body and our metabolism it
doesn't want the fat because you know
fat protects your organs and there's no
good quality energy and fat you know
that metabolism is going to go after
that flamingo and that muscle
so you got to get that muscle on
lockdown with amino acids with protein
you know once you get that muscle on
lockdown now you're going to be forcing
your metabolism just to attack into that
body fat
you know that's why it's important to
eat first thing in the morning
now i you know for somebody who's trying
to lose weight
you see you go to a gym you do the stand
master
the epileptic or whatever the [ __ ] you
do
you run you jog you swim
uh why do i see people with cups
and they drink something before they
work out and then they drink something
immediately before that workout if i'm
trying to lose weight do those protein
shakes affect me
would they affect like the ones that i
take with you when i switch off from on
it like i'll do the hemp force and then
i'll do the protein shake you give me
the sentences
uh it's two scoops it's 300 calories you
know so if you're on weight watchers
it's basically five points you know so
it's not that bad it's zero carbs uh
do i drink one of those before i go to
the gym
well for for someone who's um say if
you're uh you know you're thirty or 40
40 or maybe even 50 pounds overweight
and you're really just trying to lose
body weight you're not so much focused
on
on on muscle but
if you're really trying to lose the
weight i mean some protein shakes can
make some people feel a little bloated
can make them feel a little heavy
so some people go into the gym doing
fasted cardio which is pretty much you
know just going into the gym on an empty
gut
but but the thing is is you never want
to work out on a totally empty system so
that's why a lot of people like that
colored drink that you'll see people
sipping on will usually be like uh you
know bcaas which are branched chain
amino acids
those also have like electrolytes
antioxidants in them so at least this
way
the amino acids which are pretty much
building blocks of muscle you know
that'll help safeguard their muscles so
when they go in and do fasted cardio
they're just dropping body weight
they're not also experiencing muscle
loss with it
because we you know we all want to lose
weight but we don't want to lose our
muscle weight you know either
and um you know and you know going into
the gym on an empty stomach first thing
right in the morning you know a lot of
people don't have that um they don't
have the energy you know so a lot of
people use those pre-workout supplements
you know it's stimulant base you know
some are more like ginseng b12 from like
mood enhancement natural energy for
those that may be sensitive to caffeine
at least that'll give you some some
energy some drive just to kind of get
through your workout a little bit more
effectively you know
now uh
what about the after shake how come
that's so important
well whether you're doing you know
weights whether you're doing cardio you
know you're wearing and tearing on your
body i mean when you're in the gym
you're you know you're not growing you
know you're actually breaking down your
body your muscles even with cardio
you're working your lower extremities
your legs which are you know are your
biggest muscle group in your body so you
know the protein is think of it as like
a band-aid you know to put on your
muscles after a hard workout helps your
body bounce back a lot faster
you know even with cardio you can still
be feeling that soreness that achiness
factor which can carry through your day
could be a pain in the butt too
something i could really recommend is
glutamine and glutamine takes precedence
over all the amino acids that are out
there and that's something that you can
actually use with your protein post
workout which is after
and that'll help eliminate that soreness
by like 80 85 percent it's huge
um because the last thing you want to do
is to be feeling all sore and achy and
then you know go into the gym the next
day and break down your muscle all over
again
and that's the last thing you want
you're just gonna be spinning your wheel
so it's all about how you're bouncing
back from your workouts
and um and after that after that workout
you have that little
little anabolic window so you know the
sooner the better think of it as like if
you cut yourself
you know we start bleeding out you know
the world stops we put a band-aid on it
immediately
it's the same kind of concept you know
you break down the body you want to make
sure you're nourishing it with you know
protein and amino acids that's an
immediate band-aid post-workout
my buddy the flying jew a.k.a lisa he's
staring at me
all stoned and [ __ ] oh yeah uh he just
started a little exercise program and i
know that he's having a great time i can
see it in his face that he's uh
you know lead likes to stay inside and
lay in the bed and get his balls licked
like the rest of america
and uh
good time well you have any questions i
have a bunch of questions
so
and and
i i got i'm not
attacked i had a [ __ ] up weekend with
it so i have i have like a bunch of
questions written down
so everything you just said is great
but like let's say we went next door and
there was an identical store and there's
an identical you
he might say something completely
different like
the exact opposite of what he said i
went online and i just put in best diet
and i got the us news 2014 top diets
there were 31 top diets with eight diet
groups and they reviewed 42 diets
like while if you go to a doctor with a
broken arm for the most part they're
going to do the same thing like why are
there so many
different varying and when i first
started this i put this on twitter and
one person would say high protein one
person would say low protein
no carbs one person would say a lot of
carbs a lot of protein like why they're
so why isn't it like lose weight and do
this like why is it so many different uh
opinions on it
right well it's you're totally right man
totally right it's uh
we live in such a big market not only
with you know supplements but also with
knowledge and certain levels of
education um
you know i mean in the last five years
it's been it's crazy i've been in the
market for about eight years and it's
just in the last five years it's just
been
crazy how it's just blowing up the
supplements and the saturation of
marketing so you kind of have to
you know do your own due diligence
really and i tell everybody it's a big
experiment but you go back to the basics
remember i was growing up
in school we'd always have that little
food pyramid you know the carbs the
protein the good fats and that's it that
was like the foundation of life you know
so i was trying i always try to go back
to the basics go back to the roots um
like in the last couple of years didn't
they just change the food pyramid even
that you can't even that there's people
[ __ ] around with
of course well i mean well nowadays with
you know supply and demand um you know
you know the way our food is
you know our fruits our vegetables
aren't even as uh you know clean as it
used to be um you know with all the
pesticides you know in our foods and the
hormones that they put in our meats
uh you know i'm sure the food pyramid
has changed over the last decade with
the serving amount i remember when it
used to be like three to five servings
of fruits and vegetables you know now i
remember it went up to five to seven and
now it's up to nine to fourteen so
you know
it's unfortunate that way and that's the
beauty about some supplements too is
even if you can't get it from whole
foods at least like some free driest uh
condensed down into powdered fruit and
green supplements are actually a lot i
would say cleaner than you're actually
getting fruit and vegetables in a
produce store oh wow okay so here here's
the one that
i almost burned down at trader joe's
this weekend
so
i swear to god so i went out with my
girlfriend to dinner and we're gonna go
home and watch the fights and i wanted
to get some snacks i went into trader
joe's which you you would think is going
to be healthy
and we walked around
and an a regular sized bag of trail mix
which is nuts which is what they tell
you to eat
you look at i like i'll you look at the
calories and i know that some people say
calories down all of it but that's i
just started so i'm focusing on calories
right now but when i looked a regular
sized bag it wasn't even like a family
size bag had 17
serving uh servings in the bag
like so wow it's like
how
like how is that even and this isn't
really for you but like how is that
legal how
if
a serving size should be a bag a half a
bag
a regular sized bed up i went yesterday
to the grocery store and a bag of gummy
bears had six servings in it and it's a
bag that people are gonna eat in two
minutes
like how is that even like is that it
like how do you when you when you're
trying to lose weight like how do you
tell people
because calories are a big thing that's
the first thing you think about to to
have less of
and when they [ __ ] you with you with the
serving sizes it just like it's it it
seems like they're trying to like stop
you before you even get started but not
the interrupt or brett let me tell you
something guys
you know why there's more [ __ ] diets
than ever why so we give ourselves more
excuses yeah okay we all know the diet
you need you need to push yourself away
from the table yeah you can't eat ice
cream no matter what the serving size is
yeah you get them saying we know as
americans you [ __ ] know okay when you
wake up in the morning you can't eat
three eggs six loaves of [ __ ] bread
and six cans of coke you could eat an
egg a little [ __ ] apple and some
fruit that you know and mix it up a
little bit we all know the answer brett
but the reason why there's 52 [ __ ]
diets is so we have 52 [ __ ] excuses
to fail it's amazing
it's [ __ ] amazing you know we also
had mike dolce on who trains fighters
you know he's got a couple very
successful books and a very interesting
diet if you like that type of food but
nine other [ __ ] 10 savages that weigh
800 pounds don't eat chia seeds
and they're never gonna [ __ ] like
[ __ ] chia seeds okay
okay they got to be 800 pounds because
they don't [ __ ] like broccoli with
[ __ ] cauliflower on it so you have to
find the substitute bread as americans
and we're stuck and there's an answer
you know what
i started this whole thing when i was
418 pounds right i i let myself go with
the sleep apnea and the drugs over the
years and the binge eating
and uh one day i woke i went to hawaii
and i didn't even have three minutes of
cardio at 0.5 on a treadmill i have no
reason to lie to america or uber
and i had to quit the cigarettes and
quit the blow and walk around the
[ __ ] neighborhood and you know
embarrassed to not you know i'd go in
the pool i would never wear a shirt on
that's even more embarrassing show those
titties if you're going to jump in the
pool show those titties [ __ ] they
got hair on them who gives a [ __ ]
um
you know and i went to weight watchers
brent and
as as gay and as womany as it sounds
i dropped 118 [ __ ] pounds and i all i
did every day brett i swear to god was
hit the bag at the ymca i started at
three or four minutes
and then get on the bicycle i get on a
bicycle now and i want to puke because
after an hour you've burned 60 [ __ ]
calories
but you get on the elliptical and you
burn 500 calories in that same hour yeah
so the bike doesn't work for a guy like
me no more but i found that through
experimenting you know for the last six
months i've put on weight every week
between the kettlebells and the protein
powder and and i spoke to a friend of
mine he goes i just want you to do jiu
jitsu for two weeks
drink your protein watch your diet don't
eat your breads i've lost eight pounds
i've only been to jiu jitsu two times a
week and i went to the epileptic on hit
the punching bag so i was overworking
myself brett i was working five days a
week and gaining [ __ ] weight the
kettlebells i think whenever i touch
anything with metal on it i put weight
on it just makes me automatically
[ __ ] hungrier i think
and everything of course yeah every time
i touch a medal in the back of my mind
means oh i got permission to eat a steak
you know
well think of it think of it too man is
you know when you start lifting anything
with metal it's got weight distribution
to it so weight will break down your
muscle more aggressively than just doing
regular cardio you see so and then we
all have different you know genetic
makeup and hereditary dispositions
so you know say for some people that
lift weights they can put on muscle very
quickly
versus someone else you know so that
could just be your genetic makeup but
when you start lifting weights your
muscles just respond to that you know
so you know but yeah like you said it's
an experiment you have to run through
for yourself i've spoken to people for
years i had a friend in syracuse that
told me fruit is the worst thing you
could eat
this guy looked by the face and argued i
didn't even
i didn't get involved in the argument
because i kept thinking to myself i've
never seen nobody 800 pounds eating an
apple on television saying that he needs
help yeah you know what i'm saying i
can't stop eating oranges i'm 800
[ __ ] pounds you know it's so weird
you know what man i i find myself losing
weight when i interrupt my day with
fruit
last night my wife bought a she bought
something oh she buys those cheese puffs
for this baby i gotta taste them those
captain booty cheese pups
they can replace a blow job
got a good ring to it yeah oh my god
pirate's booty that's pirates really
good they replace a [ __ ]
if you're warmed up and you want
somebody to lick your balls do me a
favor go to rob's and buy the pirates
booty cheese puffs sit there put your
favorite tv show on eat a handful and
you won't wait no it is one bag ten
servings uh something like a lot of it
but pirates booty actually looked look
not bad
my wife gets them for the baby because
of that reason it's like a handful is 80
calories whatever it was
but i went for the pirate's boot and i
go ah
i ate a banana first
and i ate half a [ __ ] cantaloupe
and i only ate three pirates booties
instead
do you understand me dogs so you gotta
cut deals with yourself it's about
sacrifice also i would love to eat that
whole bag of pirates oh my god yeah a
couple weeks ago i ate a pot cookie and
i went home my wife woke up the next
morning she goes where's the [ __ ]
chief pups i go i'm on my way to get
another two bags i destroyed them last
night because i can't believe you ate
the baby's [ __ ] cheeseburger i go
don't tell me say something a [ __ ]
pot cookie
oh my god
uh no it's nutrition listen
for years i thought running up hills and
[ __ ] you could run up all the [ __ ]
hills you want everybody knows you're
absolutely right it's 80 nutrition until
you start cutting the mayonnaise out
and uh putting away that bag of chips
and uh
you know that's when things start
happening but again brett we live in a
society that nobody wants to take
responsibility for anything
right you know nobody wants to uh
really what would you think with what
you your products that you have done
i take a lot of your products and i'm
very happy with them
i love the gluten core you know if i uh
before i go to i was taking it after my
workouts
and still being sore and i want to go on
and curse you out
but it wasn't until i started drinking
them at night and replacing them as a
meal
that i really started feeling the
effects of the glutathione
great you know before i hit the crib a
little milkshake i wake up feeling like
[ __ ] you know
johnny bananas
yeah well you know when you're sleeping
you're that's when your body's you know
you know most of effectively when it's
really repairing itself rejuvenating is
during your sleep cycle so that's a
great time to use a you know protein
glutamine supplement
but you know this is just like in the
food industry you know in the supplement
industry is a huge market so
you know i mean my products are great i
stand by my products but it's just
because over the years i've done a lot
of due diligence and a lot of comparing
to different products and that's what
you have to do with with food and even
with supplements is just compare
supplement facts and everything will
have a supplement fact on the back if it
does if oh i'm sorry if it doesn't then
i wouldn't buy it you know but you
always want to have um that comparison
of supplements uh just to compare apples
to apples and you just want to try to
find the most effective the most
cleanest
uh product that could best suit your um
you know the goals that you're shooting
for
fred well we always have this
conversation
and you're very good explaining it but i
want you to explain you know like i said
to you when i spoke to you i go i want
you to talk to me the way you
speak to your customers because you're a
beautiful person man
i've watched the way you handle
different customers and i'll tell you
there's most days that if i had your job
i know you want to get in the car at the
end of the day
and shoot up the 405 and jump off a
cliff but you've never given me that
appearance i've seen you early in the
morning and you've always been a
gentleman and i've seen you at 7 30 at
night after a long day
and you've always taken your time to
speak to people and
if somebody comes in to see you we
always talk about protein powders
and you broke it down for me last week
about why your protein batter is a
little better with the whey protein and
it's
uh
what what was the word time released
right
it's more of a blem there's a there's
something such a huge market for protein
i mean that's the most popular thing you
know whether whatever goal that you're
trying to get again it goes back to that
basic that you know that little food
pyramid you know you always want you
know a good protein in your diet you
know
um
but um but you know a lot of proteins
out there you know first off they have a
lot of fillers just even like in food
you know a lot of these it'll stay like
you know the supplement facts and then
there'll be a little description of
saying other ingredients
it's like a paragraph long of like all
these fillers of you know more salt
sodium you know potassium iodines and
all this other just dunk that shouldn't
really be in um you know a protein it
should just be protein you know it
should be simple
you know a lot of a lot of proteins have
gluten a lot of them have sugars
um a lot of them have a lot of uh even
sodium maybe like four to six hundred
milligrams of sodium per serving which
is salt so that could cause excess
bloating so you know just it all depends
what you're really trying to do but um
but the protein that you're on the pro 5
i mean that's still a phenomenal product
you know just you just always want to
look at you know the calorie you know
the fat the saturated fats the sodium
the sugars um
you know and also the ingredient list
and making sure you're not taking in all
this extra gunk you know words that i
can't even pronounce you know
you know it's funny i went to uh bert
crisis for a party about a month ago
and he has a friend that was trying to
uh put together a company you know he
fell in love with a young girl and
sometimes when you meet a young girl
they talk into bad [ __ ] ideas
and he got talked into an idea put money
up for a protein ice cream bar
and when i first saw him like a year ago
he was very gung-ho and
blah blah blah blah blah blah he was
jumping up and down and he was counting
his money already and
when i just saw him recently it was just
him and i for a couple split seconds i
go how you doing
how's the business and he goes i never
ever ever
was more baffled by the vitamin and
supplement business
because you know when you
get a protein powder it's amazing how
much garbage there is in there
he goes and i'm finding out that you
know the same thing goes with these ice
cream bars that when i go to
make them the people that do all this
specialty stuff are like you know what
you don't need all this [ __ ] they'll pay
for it even with this [ __ ] in it it's
amazing and he was surprised how many
scams there are and how many uh
but there's some companies like yours
that really believe in it listen man
uh people have to see results you know
it's always funny if you look on i have
what do i have google one of those pages
uh what's the other one lee that i have
yahoo
okay if you look at yahoo they have all
these results like all these stories you
know uh
uh frankie edgar knocks out bj penn
somebody uses the n-word for obama you
know today if you but if you scroll down
there'll be an ad by gnc let's say
that's promoted by gnc they just bought
an ad but you don't see it
and it said you know something about
read what everybody's talking about this
uh pill they have that gives you more
oxygen and all this [ __ ] and it's
amazing how much media is involved
right in the market you know when i was
a kid you had joe wieder you're a young
man lee's a young man when i was a young
man if you wanted to get in shape you
bought muscle and fitness
and you brought it home and there was
one company yeah it was joe weeda his
company also put the [ __ ] magazine
out
so it was like stealing it's like what
i'm saying i mean if you think about all
the [ __ ] big companies that's it this
is the same thing they do it's a
magazine that enticed they hire readers
that that that they're all in the same
bed but joe weeder put together inositol
and clothe line that was a fat burger 30
years ago
you know uh people were actually going i
remember i remember going to dinner with
guys in high school at the time i
weighed 200 pounds and they probably
weighed 260 270 they were huge and they
beat in calamari with hot sauce dipping
bread in the hot sauce and after the
dinner
they popped three joe weed of fat
burgers
and i'd say what did you just eat and
they go fat burners this calamari is
going to disappear and i would [ __ ]
i would [ __ ] howl even at 18 i wasn't
a nutritionist i was just some young
coked up criminal and i would sit there
i would sit there at the table and go
you actually believe
that if you eat so i go what is the
dosage it goes they say the pop two
every four hours
so we pop four since we're a little more
so you actually believe that americans
that actually believe that there's
[ __ ] fat burners
brent there are americans that believe
that if they pop a pill
before they eat they go to [ __ ]
burger king
they will lose weight
we'll like mention then it's it's that
um
it's that it's that it's that
advertisement man it's that um it's just
one of those other 52 ways to make us
fail it's part of that saturation of the
marketing you know hey take a pill lose
weight the easy way out that's what
everybody wants of course anybody we're
human of course we want the easy way you
know it's
you know but you know it's uh
yeah you have to look past the
saturation the marketing and the
advertisements because uh and even more
so than nowadays i mean children can you
tell us i mean back in your day i mean
was was that was it so saturated with
with marketing because i mean even
nowadays man it's crazy because
even in the middle of the night if i'm
just kind of flipping through the
channels i mean i've noticed commercials
are long as heck if i'm watching a
little tv series or something these
commercials are longer than the tv
series when i was a kid growing up
commercials were only on for maybe a
minute minute and a half and now they're
exceeding to like four minutes
and they're always hitting us with like
buy this consume this have this you need
this more stuff be happier you know and
they [ __ ] block fat people at night
you're sitting there you get your feet
up you already know you're a fat [ __ ]
nothing's gonna change
you got your [ __ ] stool up you're
scratching your nuts you got chips ahoy
you got a 64-ounce coke and also they
got some skinny guy doing [ __ ] px90
at 2 30 in the morning some black dude
that [ __ ] the white chicks at the gym
they're all laying there all [ __ ] up
they got sp
it's like these [ __ ] companies they
know this we know that some joe smol was
just sitting on his couch chilling at
two in the morning
i'll buy that eighty-two dollars
remember two years ago the shaker every
fat dude bought the shaker listen you've
been drinking martinis for 20 years you
didn't lose a [ __ ] ounce now you're
gonna shake up a [ __ ] shaker that's
gonna make you [ __ ] lose weight
people
will do anything to avoid
what the road is did you do you see they
brought back the little thing that you
put around your stomach and it like
shakes yeah they brought that back i saw
a commercial for it did you talk about
it
you know what i wish there was a pill i
would be the first one to take it but
there ain't no [ __ ] pills there ain't
nothing you gotta walk you gotta drink
water something you know i didn't drink
water for 20 years i thought water was
like [ __ ] evil like if i went to your
house and you offered me a glass of
water i'd never come back like you go
for what you know what we don't have
walrus juice to coke what happened what
happened the dollar store is out of
[ __ ] pineapple juice get your [ __ ]
together brett it's uh always a pleasure
to go to the store and talk to you where
you located tell these [ __ ] chinooks
well the shop i work at is uh it's in
north hollywood it's uh 4844
lankershim boulevard it's like right
there in the noho district
um you're next to what i work at you're
next to the [ __ ] uh the the theater
there used to be a russian weed store
there they're done
the [ __ ] theater with the ball had a
guy with a bunch of people now friday
night's late night [ __ ] doing [ __ ]
projects you're next to that [ __ ]
condom supermarket i love them
they just
and we're also go go figure right across
the street from a kfc so you have a
little test you can either you know go
across the street to be healthy or you
got the kfc right across the street and
that's crazy because the word on the
street is i don't need kfc but the word
on the street is that's the worst kfc
in the history of [ __ ] like the one
people fat people get together and like
that's the worst kfc
you got to go to the one up on laurel
canyon there that's the good part oh
that's popeyes that's where they go
because somebody was telling me nah [ __ ]
that kfc that's a nasty one that's a
good neighbor where we're at they're
they're trying to build up north
hollywood
i love it i love living in this side of
town i love going on lancashire and i
love stopping in by you and
like i said if you guys are looking to
change your life and
you know you want to talk to somebody
just about your little supplements like
you said it's 80 [ __ ] diet you know
and i'm guilty for it as much as anybody
else you know i go to eat with my wife
and the baby next you know i'm tasting
their macaroni and cheese next thing you
know i'm stealing something now i'm like
i'm [ __ ] for the day yeah that goes
eight wait watch your points i'm [ __ ]
done you know what i'm saying but uh it
all starts with nutrition and brent i'm
happy that
you took the time to call in today i
know you sleep till about [ __ ] 7 30
you're a young man
you're right no it's all good you're out
late drink uh
you are late dressed up in white
slinging dick i saw your facebook
picture
oh [ __ ] you went to [ __ ] vegas
dressed in white like [ __ ] hector
level in 76.
did you have white shoes on to boot
yeah yeah you got it you gotta have uh
yeah stuff y'all color coordinating
you're a bad [ __ ] let me tell
you something man uh
i was a [ __ ] up kid so i know when
somebody's [ __ ] up when they're young
you're a nice young man man you got a
great life ahead of you
thank you very much for taking the time
mr tack to call in lee any last
questions you're gonna go see brett yeah
can i ask one more question no no yeah
you can ask them all you [ __ ] want
all right so
i know cooking for yourself is better
but i know there's a lot of guys like me
who aren't
aren't really into cooking so i've been
looking for restaurants to go to and
look assuming that skinny kitchen i
found over the weekend there's a place
called chop stop at the salads are those
places actually good like when you see
like low calorie or at like chili's when
they have like a light menu is that
stuff like is that
helping us at all or is that just
marketing and it's not doing [ __ ]
you know what it's uh this is my opinion
man i mean i have a lot of customers
that go to that skinny kitchen yeah i
love it um now i've never personally
been there so i can't have any say in it
but uh but i mean i've seen their menu
because a customer actually had a
marketing guy bringing in um one of
their little like catering menus so i
was kind of looking over and doing some
known due diligence and it looks pretty
legit okay um and again i've got a lot
of great feedback from customers yeah
it's delicious
right now not not to
now that i know the skinny kitchen's
kind of like a little mom pop kind of
shop you know what i'm saying um but now
and i'm not out to diss anybody but you
know just like a chili's or uh
say uh applebee's i mean these are more
like
corporate jeans that do a lot of
marketing these are the chains that you
would see on television you know um and
that that's where they put a lot of
their money into the marketing so
you know i think this you know maybe
lower calorie lower carb type of thing
may not be as
may not be as truthful as maybe like a
mom and pop i would put a little bit
more trust into a little mom-pop shop of
people who have a little integrity of
just you know trying to you know run a
successful business uh
you know you know what i'm saying you
know versus like a corporate you know
iran restaurant team
putting all their money into the
marketing and the advertisement you know
what i'm saying
okay yeah but but bottom but bottom line
nothing beats
not only price of just going out and
buying your own food and then just
cooking it there at home because any
restaurant you really go to
they're going to put something in it
that's going to entice you to make it
you know taste good they're going to
want to get the addicted to it so you
come back and buy more yeah you know so
um so it's always the cleanest
alternative just go buy your own food
cook it at home um that's the cleanest
alternative and you're also saving a lot
of money yeah just buying your own food
you know they really jack up the price i
was i bought a whole bunch of 100
calorie treats yesterday
they really jack up the price for the
healthy stuff and it's like absolutely
and there's there was a commercial on
get any any drink any size at mcdonald's
for a dollar and then my girlfriend and
i stopped at 7-eleven to get waters for
the gym it was three bucks for two
waters
like what the [ __ ]
why am i paying attention to the waters
and 99 cents for 10 gallons of soda even
the water business is starting to get
suspect to me the last couple of years
yeah
well what did i know it was clean water
all of a sudden there's a [ __ ] lake
and everybody's jumping up and down and
the dolphins are clean
you know you go to [ __ ] i went to
malibu yesterday when you jump out of
the ocean there's a hazmat guy there now
my wife got tired of foot last week it's
still on there you understand me that's
the [ __ ] that's down in malibu i
swear to god i smell like i had a
thousand odors on me yesterday oil
bodies new orleans japanese radiation
sushi [ __ ] i smelt like a [ __ ] clam
i hugged the kid when we got home we all
went in the [ __ ] shower like a family
unfucking believable you know where they
getting all this clean mountain [ __ ]
waterfront i want to see this [ __ ]
mountain
you borrowed the source yeah i want to
see this [ __ ] mountain that we're
paying a dollar for by the way
that [ __ ] water you guys sell is very
[ __ ] good and again i don't believe
nothing i don't believe periodicals or
testimonials or nothing you know in the
old days people would show up with a bag
of coke with a purple thing oh it turned
purple must be good coke give me a yak
of that [ __ ] if my eyeball ain't
spinning it ain't [ __ ] good all right
so
i took the water in jiu jitsu last
tuesday i was doing backflips i was
doing all my plateaus you should have
seen me i was johnny on the spot i had
oxygen i didn't drink the water on
wednesday i took a [ __ ] uh a heart
you know the little
wonder
the little dollar a day that you take
for your heart i went in there just to
thin the blood out it wasn't the same
that water is pretty good that p3 water
that [ __ ] thing marky wallberg put
together with
i don't know who his partner is again
where he finds this [ __ ] water
everybody's finding this [ __ ] water
and geysers
i see nothing i see i see puddles with
[ __ ] bird [ __ ]
i love you brent go see this guy over at
neutral what is it again my brother yeah
yeah miss your shop nutrish shop go see
him he's knowledgeable and most
important he's a gentleman you know like
i tell people all the time brett
everybody's got protein powders
everybody's got water everybody's got
cups
it's the customer service and when it
comes to that you're the top man thank
you very much for being you and for
being a great little young christian
young man i love you guys
i like how you use christian and
[ __ ] in the same sense
we're all sinners and [ __ ] listen
some chicks up to your dick really good
right you swap and spit with it what she
just suck a dick on seven
right now you're a [ __ ] by proxy
so at the end of the day we're sinners
and [ __ ] all of us who gives a
[ __ ] i love you
hey i love you to you jeff it's always
good talking to you man i'll see you
soon i'll see you this week buddy
all right buddy take care
what lee what what lady did you learn
something i did the fact that you're not
selling a button that says i'm a [ __ ]
collector by proxy is a shame let me
explain something to you
yeah when your chick sucks your dick
wait that's the first dick she sucks
yeah
so what the [ __ ] there you are mopping
it up without the horror movie like
you're in love you know it's like that
movie as good as it gets he's licking
the dog and the guy goes where did you
find him eating some [ __ ] dirty
diaper then you are swapping a spit with
your dog like [ __ ] your [ __ ] romeo
and juliet you know what i'm saying get
it together
it's monday [ __ ] july the 7th who
the [ __ ] are you kidding the party's
over it's a monday you got a second
chance to do whatever the [ __ ] you want
to do you want to be a lawyer [ __ ] go
down to usc lie to him i don't give a
[ __ ] tell him right i'm [ __ ] mexican
i don't give a [ __ ] i want to learn the
law where's thomas jefferson at let me
talk to that [ __ ] who's running
[ __ ] in this [ __ ] place okay you want
to be a [ __ ] jew whatever you want to
be
today's the day become a jew become a
jew [ __ ] tell them what to suck your
dick put a yarmulke on well you don't
need to get ordained
maybe you gotta go somewhere oh yeah
you're a jew now it's the same thing
just make yourself a jew
show up like donald sterling with an
envelope black people love you everybody
loves you filipinos let me give a shout
out to some beautiful [ __ ] people
here this cheaper chew is kicking in oh
huh they should get a shout out for that
oh yeah yeah yeah my man nate molly
loves you cocksuck i know what you
[ __ ] promise stop moping around the
house get it together grab your balls
stick a finger up yes tell molly to suck
the juice out of that [ __ ] love stick
it's over lauren
rosenkur you know i love you baby i see
you hanging in there jose gamma you bad
[ __ ]
talking lair i can't wait to see you in
vegas in two weeks
the real scuba steve
ras dude christopher santiago
listen i got some [ __ ] people who
sent me some product i like those hit
little [ __ ] cigarettes if you want to
talk about sponsorship i'll help you out
i really enjoyed those little hit
cigarettes you know what i'm saying they
were very nice there's twelve thousand
[ __ ] hits per cigarette oh i don't
know i get like two stairs out of a blue
there's an e-cigarette i dug your
product thank you very much for send it
to me also wax pen sent me some [ __ ]
wax pens i tell you what i liked about
them i could put some [ __ ] weed in it
too so it takes the weed it takes the
[ __ ] wax i want to give you a shout
out waxy pen they sent me some extra
coils you some bad [ __ ] up
there thank you very much i'm giving
them out at the [ __ ] uh at the free
[ __ ] podcast and i gave one over to
the girl at the weave store by my house
you know i'm saying so don't don't
forget about nothing just cause you sent
me something don't mean i ain't here for
you what lee what what what [ __ ]
look at you i gave you 10 milligrams of
a chibo juice
and you and you ain't complaining but
it's good no you feel good i can tell
sometimes you're red in the face i don't
know this is you look like jesus before
they stabbed them well yeah when you
give me my second green horde another
night i kind of you got to do it you
[ __ ] sacrifice and listen man
when you're a christian or a [ __ ]
catholic what do they call you a sinner
we're sinners we're [ __ ] [ __ ] suckers
here at the church and what's happening
now you swap spit with the chicks you
suck the [ __ ] you swap spit with it [ __ ]
it you got cooties now
we all just hit him with a shot of that
[ __ ] breath right back at you get him
saying what else is going on just
because we had nutrishop on listen man
everybody's got a good product and it
goes behind it the reason why i deal
with honor is the same reason i got a
good product every time i hit ricardo
with a question over there boom i got an
answer back that's the most important
[ __ ] thing to me is customer service
customer satisfaction yesterday somebody
hit me they downloaded a cd it didn't
work boom i said it to lee lee takes
care of it we don't [ __ ] around and then
we don't need your [ __ ] five hours i
want you to be happy you understand me i
don't want your [ __ ] fight i want you
to be happy [ __ ] with anything
whether it's the podcast
for lee whether it's so that's i just
want you to be happy that's customer
service that's something that nobody
pays you to do that's something you have
to have in your heart when you look at
somebody you go i hope you're happy with
what happened dog when i showed you a
coke rock it was a [ __ ] coke rock
okay that's all i got to say that's
customer [ __ ] service same thing
stands with honor they don't [ __ ] around
if you want supplements go to somebody
else if you want optimization you go to
[ __ ] honor you want to be the best
animal you could be you want you want to
be thinking on 15 [ __ ] cylinders you
pop a couple of those alpha brains you
jerk off and you smoke a [ __ ] number
and you leave the house you see how
clear-headed you are you're not walking
around all [ __ ] up with that lump scum
in your [ __ ] sack or throwing you off
and throws your equilibrium off you take
some alpha brain alpha brain don't [ __ ]
around if it don't change your life it
doesn't make you feel better and clean
send it back we got a money back
guarantee no questions asked one time
only don't do it tight squares we'll
send somebody down there stab you in the
[ __ ] net go to onyx they got the
kettlebells they got the shroom tech
they got the coral [ __ ] i'm telling you
guys the digest enzymes they got the
testosterone booster
when it comes to your [ __ ] health and
health health optimization and you
you're getting [ __ ] tremendous
[ __ ] uh uh what's the word i'm
looking for here results from your
workouts go to [ __ ] honor.com go to
joeytheirs.net order a geek patch while
you're there go to on it order something
from them say 10 percent what do you put
in the box you put it in church church
c-h-u-r-c-h it don't take no spelling
bee [ __ ] champion to let you know
that one ball sniffers on it go there
right now why [ __ ] around we gotta have
this conversation every day the same
thing with hulufuckingplus.com my wife
lives on [ __ ] hulu i don't even know
what shows she watches shows
plural you understand me shows
plural that's what hulu plus got to you
you think i'd be [ __ ] around with
hulu plus this long if they weren't the
[ __ ] eight what 799 a month
set lily why are you sitting there
looking around like a [ __ ] like one
of jerry's kids on a bus ride you're
sitting there looking around like on a
bus ride what the [ __ ] the matter you
get it together guys
write that one down jerry's kid's on a
bus ride i like that one anyway the same
thing hulu plus don't [ __ ] around so
what are some of the shows they have
they have all their tons of kids shows
they have bob's burgers if you if you
miss like a lot of people can't don't
stay up late for the like the nightly
shows if it's tonight's show they have
all that stuff they put it on the next
day next day what do you think you're
[ __ ] you wake up it's there boom hulu
plus for all your shows listen i'm gonna
give you two weeks for free two weeks
[ __ ] you don't get that on the
tv yet two weeks nobody gives you that
[ __ ] when was the last time you went you
get your dicks up and they said well
we'll give you a dick sucking nothing
you get who got you got to pay first
with me two weeks for free 7.99 a month
you go to the huluplus.com box and what
do you press you put joey joey j-o-e-y
j-o-e-y that's the code to get you two
weeks for free and after that 7.99 a
month for [ __ ] everything you see on
tv at the [ __ ] at your fingertips do
you understand me at your fingertips you
can watch this stuff you can watch it
binging
you know what i'm saying you have to sit
there and watch one episode at a time we
ain't got time for that [ __ ] you wait
till you get six of them you smoke two
[ __ ] joints you tell mama to bend
over you eat that ass you sit back boom
when you watch your six episodes like a
gentleman go to the box today
huluplus.com and press joey j-o-e-y and
while you're at it why are you walking
around everybody wants to be fidel
castro even lee everybody wants to walk
around like with a beard it's my dream
like we got a [ __ ] revolution going
on or something shave that [ __ ] thing
it's like wearing sunglasses i can't see
the real you we want to see the real you
[ __ ] between the beard the
tattoo the swats that got in your
forehead you're gonna get 70 [ __ ]
years eventually you gotta accessorize
that's right you gotta accessorize
[ __ ] dollar shave club sharpen up
one dollar six dollars and nine dollars
a month every month delivered right to
your door on it too they'll deliver
right to your [ __ ] door it's called
stay on it they do the same [ __ ] dollar
shave club you get four razors sent to
your door every [ __ ] month you're
gonna leave the house you don't gotta
stay in the pharmacy where's your card
where's your customer gratitude [ __ ]
customer paper bag yeah you wanna pay
for a bag one dollar six dollars and
nine dollars for one dollar you get four
single blades for six dollars you get
four double blades for nine dollars you
get four double blades with the aloe
strip makes your face nice they got the
one white charlies for your [ __ ] you
pop them in your ass you pop
counterclockwise or the other way your
[ __ ] muffler is spotless when people
sniff your [ __ ] they're like where
were you where the [ __ ] have you been
eating peppermint patties your whole
life dollarshaveclub.com
why [ __ ] around also to my main man
jeremy at
escapepodtank.com
if you want to save thousands thousands
not [ __ ] a couple yards sticks
thousands on a [ __ ]
uh
floatation tank floatation tank for your
house business whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do they just got the the just
the what's the name of it
just the tank model you save 150 but
joey i don't have two or three g's
financing is available go to
escapepodtank.com go to the page there's
an 800 number call jeremy or answer all
your questions he knows about [ __ ] and
everything tell him what he knows about
his shoes all those questions everything
all you have to answer all your [ __ ]
questions got all the answers for you
plus he'll save you money which is what
this podcast does shop around i don't
give a [ __ ] put escape pod tank to the
[ __ ] test i [ __ ] dare you you're
going to save a buck 50 off to just a
tank model and 250 just for dropping the
name flying jew [ __ ] jews spicks joey
beers boom you get 250 dollars off who
gives you that type of love in your life
i don't want it on a [ __ ] monday
nobody [ __ ] that's why we're here
so what do you got planned for today
lisa well i'm gonna work out um what
time are you doing this time
i was gonna go after this because i'm
pretty high um but i didn't bring shorts
i guess i have to go home
i'll work out kind of shorts you bring
to the gym you get nice little tight
shorts boys no i like i like the gym i
like having pockets i always feel like
an [ __ ] because you can't carry your
wallet without pockets you bring your
wallet to the gym no no but like later
on we're like i just i i always put the
[ __ ] lock
in the trunk it's in the locker put
don't put in your locker that's why i
used to make most of my scams and they
said i had a kid that would lock up your
boy would watch you get to know he
worked at the gym and when you walk in
they don't ever bring your phone all you
got to bring into the gym is you [ __ ]
ipod don't bring your phone in there
either ain't nobody going to die
we'll get it together stupid because
then you accept phone calls i want you
to be fresh when you're in there i want
your mind to be thinking about the
future what jokes you're going to write
what are you going to do when you lose
this weight how you going to be at the
beach [ __ ] slinging dick with mexican
women you know what helps and i'm going
to have to start breaking my ipad is is
movies on the elliptical makes you go by
like nothing
that's tremendous just focus on what i
want you to go there and clean up that
[ __ ] head of yours look at that
you're the only jew you got no gel on
your hair i want you to clean up what's
in the coconut don't worry about the
[ __ ] movies just put music on i want
you to think when you think of how we
could do the podcast how you can write
jokes how you can make your dick bigger
don't worry about the entertainment
everybody wants to bring a magazine what
are you going to read this ain't no
[ __ ] library this is the gym did
rocky robo reed when he was at the gym
you see rocky about ball watching an
ipad at the gym [ __ ] no he you focus
on the journey ahead of you i want you
to be there
no i'm there i'll [ __ ] around here i
want you to be there
i take the ipod and i go back i go back
to my weaknesses i think of a time when
it was [ __ ] dark and i try to get
myself out of that i bring myself to
emotion sometimes
i drive myself to [ __ ] the emotion of
being stuck there again and how i felt
and how people are walking around
feeling sometimes because the only way
for me to do this podcast and for really
for me to get through these people is to
bring myself there to prove to you
[ __ ] that you could be
somewhere dark and within 10 minutes you
can have light in your [ __ ] life it's
not going to always be dark you're going
to have darkness but when you go to work
out i want you to think of your life i
want you to [ __ ] all that movies and
because then you're not you're not
thinking about what you're doing i went
and went to 33 minute mark i want you to
look at the clock and go i got 27
minutes left [ __ ] that [ __ ]
cheeseburger
[ __ ] that [ __ ] slice of pizza now you
don't want because sometimes you go to
the gym and we go if i go to the gym
i'm gonna eat that cookie
yeah and when you're under 33 million
you're huffing and puffing and that
salty sweats going in your eyeballs
right and you're tasting you can smell
the odor coming up from you i smell like
an old man have you smelt me lately i
haven't i smelt like an old man
it's disgusting you know and i want you
to think and sometimes like i said i
think back when i'm 27 because i want to
think about lee's going through right
now sometimes i go back to when i'm 25 i
go to 1988 and i think back to what the
[ __ ] was i going through boy was i
[ __ ] scared boy
did i not believe i could do anything
that i really had in my mind that i was
a piece of [ __ ] lee i really [ __ ]
believe that i wasn't gonna accomplish
anything in my life you know and then i
i think back to getting on stage and i
think about how i felt then how i felt
that i was just going to kill myself
like every time i get on stage you just
want to kill yourself because you're not
funny and then that that sparks me to go
to jiu jitsu
that makes me go you know what i got to
go to jiu jitsu tomorrow
because i don't even want to be that bad
and i know that if i was bad at
something because i got i tried it you
know i try to take myself to these dark
places man because it'll get my writing
better it'll make me better because it
makes me see the [ __ ] journey so i
want you to do the same thing when
you're working out so three years from
now somebody comes to you and they're
100 pounds overweight you go listen dog
this is what you're doing you put your
mind there and you think because if not
you're not feeling what you're going
through okay and you go to yoga and you
breathe you feel your body
you [ __ ] i did you know uh lately i've
been doing those things those to stretch
my back okay i was working out and not
stretching afterward
it's the worst thing you could do
you know a lot of people stretch a lot
before they work out where people say
you can pull your muscles if you're not
warmed up properly so i always walk
around or something or do something even
if i just jump up and down and then
stretch a little bit then do the
epileptic and then when i'm coming down
off the epolitico i stretch i really
stretch hard boom i breathe i let the
breath but i wasn't stretching my back
so i was having back problems i was
walking around like red [ __ ] fox you
know and i don't want to walk around
like that no more so now i've been
stretching so after you're working don't
forget the [ __ ] stretch what else you
got planned for today you're going to do
a podcast for rick time yeah then rick
tonight i got to watch a movie probably
uh
and then just a movie you guys going
tonight i'm not sure i have to have to
talk to work
i probably know but i'm i'm really
[ __ ] up right now um
and then
the last week was kind of slow and i've
been getting some some tweets i've i've
almost gotten all the uh proposals i
want for the app all right so get it
together
what are you doing today oh can i
mention one thing i gotta mention if you
uh at least hyatt.com if you want i'm
having a sale on shirts use code jew me
down and you get 10 bucks off t-shirts
you're a [ __ ] savage what do i got
today today i'm gonna do a little
workout i'm thinking about going to jiu
jitsu tonight if i can make it by eight
o'clock i gotta write
i'm getting ready for the san jose
improv you know san jose is always a
[ __ ] crazy part
auntie dolores is coming again
i got some [ __ ] showing up some
gangsters some mexicans some [ __ ]
raider fans uh it's a jiu jitsu weekend
up there so i have a lot of jiu jitsu
people going up there i think i'm going
to stop by guerrilla jiu jitsu saturday
morning for the 10 30 g class oh cool so
i'm very excited about the week up in
san jose i always am next week i'm in
[ __ ] viva las vegas at the south
point with my main man steve simone and
[ __ ] making it happen and the week after
that i'm in beautiful pioneer comedy
club in reno [ __ ] nevada i got to get
my plane ticket today but something
really weird happened man uh what a
great listener said that uh he heard me
speak about santana
and his uncle was santana if i wanted to
go see him in irvine whoa to 26 and go
backstage and meet carlos and i'm
[ __ ]
you know uh it took me two days to reply
to the kid because i was so overwhelmed
i'm really in hell but i committed to
this reno date i have to do it if not
i'd be right there i'd love to meet
santana and uh
people have no idea you know what
santana did said you know it's funny how
this great man like martin luther king
was a a great man he fought for
black rights and you know
but if you really look at taking nothing
away from martin luther king somebody
like muhammad ali did more
for the african-americans you know uh
you know you get the chinese people you
know they built our railroads they gave
us the orange you know chinese people
they did they did they gave us the
[ __ ] arms a lot of people don't know
that um
bruce lee really
transformed the border you know jujitsu
i see more people eating asahi more
people eat brazilian food now because
jiu jitsu opens opens up that culture
you know what i'm saying uh [ __ ] the
the the [ __ ] towers go down and
people eat more [ __ ] hummus you know
what i'm saying the next thing you know
of the taliban spreading hummus oh my
god and these suckers are eating hummus
with chips oh my god i love this red
pepper hummus meanwhile the taliban's
getting [ __ ] stronger but you're
eating [ __ ] hummus [ __ ] uh
i feel that with even spanish people man
carlos santana if you listen to that
[ __ ] early album uh
get some early early i forget that
you know abraxas
[ __ ] i'm being a kid
and putting the
on and being proud like i could hear the
spanish
influence in the music yeah we're going
to close the santana come on
uh put abraxas on it yeah it's [ __ ]
just just
so
you know i always when i wrote back i
said it would be
callers i don't want to do a podcast i
don't want to do nothing like that
i just want to talk to him because
to me he's a real [ __ ] pioneer you
know he went to the music label and said
this is what i do and they're like we
don't know about these maracas and these
[ __ ] mexicans and [ __ ]
is that a braxtous the album the full
album yeah
abraxas 1970. this is i'm being a little
kid and getting this from columbia house
this is when you beat columbia house and
you got eight albums for a penny yeah
and you gave a wrong address and you
sent it to the wrong
it could be addre
speed that up a little bit how far a
minute two minutes how long i like that
it's great
when i was seven seven this is what i
was listening to for you dumb
[ __ ] that are still at home
watching dora the explorer i was
dropping this at seven on an eight track
upstairs in my attic not even getting
high
just listening to this [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me
so you hate specs put this on
you hate that mexican down the block
that has the lawnmower before you judge
them put this on
you hate that [ __ ] lady who sells
your [ __ ] tacos and won't give you
the extra hot sauce
put this on [ __ ]
feel it you [ __ ] suckers it's monday
smoke a number do a bong hit do
something write your goals
we gotta get out of here i'm getting too
emotional
you hear those congos right there you're
like but we're white people why are we
listening to this native music why are
you selling us gum
because
there's somebody that was blind why are
you selling us g clay [ __ ]
i love you guys
stay black we'll see you wednesday night
we got a great guest sat uh eight
o'clock wednesday night
on the ninth is it the ninth
yeah should be
save the ads right over this don't turn
this okay and i wasn't going to now that
the show's over don't forget to sign up
for a free trial of hulu plus hulu plus
has depends on thousands of videos
anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast and get an extended free trial
of google plus i'm going to go to
huluplus.com joey or go to joeydiaz.net
and click on the hulu plus banner and
don't forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
wages sent to your door every month for
fractional weight paid retail
now go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash church or just go to
ideas.net and click on the dollar
shipping banner and then
on it go there for all of your
optimization
pills uh the apple brain